apple's m1 max laptops have one huge
downside one weakness where windows
laptops especially with rtx graphics
really excel now we know that these
machines are amazing for photo editing
for video editing for web browsing for
battery life for coding all that's
phenomenal but the big weak spot is 3d
rendering well today we're going to test
out the latest updates the fix that it's
gonna make 3d rendering much faster
we'll see how much it improved compared
to b4 along with how it compares to an
rtx 3080 equipped laptop that's very
powerful both plugged in and we're also
going to unplug it to see how the
performance compares when both of them
are running with the same amount of
wattage about 46 watts for the gpu and
we're gonna do that with the alpha build
of blender that was just released now
blender is free it is extremely popular
amongst people online because anybody
can learn it and use it there are a
couple of major game studios that use it
so it's a massive program and for a
while now we're only using cycle cpu
based rendering it takes forever now
this is a huge downside obviously we
have redshift that does work with metal
it still needs optimizations a lot of
other programs need to be optimized but
this is a huge one for the community now
along with this downside there are some
other downsides to these m1 mac so i'm
actually working on a video giving you
guys all the weaknesses of this system
and if you guys want to see that video
you want to see some reasons why you
might not want to buy one make sure you
guys subscribe down below that's going
to be coming up very soon but for now
let's go ahead and jump in i'm going to
start out with a couple projects that
we've been testing within the last month
and a half just to see how much faster
we can get these to run with cycles
let's come down to the settings right
here we're gonna switch from ev which is
what we were using for really quick
renders people use it for preview some
people use it for gaming it's a good
engine but cycles is the one that we
want what most people use for high
quality and we're gonna switch over to
experimental right here and that will
allow us to switch over to gpu compute
and now it is not grayed out meaning it
will run now we're gonna run this first
test but i also want to open up my
activity monitor go to window and gpu
history that way we can actually see how
much gpu usage we actually get and let's
go ahead and hit render bam look at that
right there our graphics card is maxed
out and we are running both cpu and gpu
together uh you guys see the cpu is at
84 so that's not maxed out all the way
but it is close and let's see how long
this takes and bam it is finished that
is way faster than before it took a
minute and 18 seconds compared to four
minutes and 10 seconds previously that
is 3.2 times faster but this is a simple
project let's get a little bit more
difficult and then we'll do the ones
that you guys have tested at home this
is the party tug project it is a lot
more difficult there's a bunch of
shaders here right now everything is
loading up getting ready so it's a lot
more complex a lot of effects and
particles here all right the test is
finished and it's interesting that this
is one of the few times that i actually
hear the fans spinning up they're about
half speed or so very quiet still we're
hitting the cpu pretty hard and maxing
out the gpu for a time of a minute and
54 seconds from 754 down to 154 or over
four times faster results
4.15 that is impressive now this next
project is probably one of the most
popular blender projects as far as
benchmarking so you guys may have tested
it there's tons of tests online which
you can compare these results to which
is why i want to run it and i'm going to
set this to render and the other thing
that i want to tell you guys is that you
have to remember this is the alpha build
the very first one that just came out
it's not even a beta version so people
are online are saying that there are so
much more optimizations that are going
to happen this system is going to get a
lot faster this is the very very first
result and bam look at that that's
probably the biggest difference we've
seen from eight minutes and 45 seconds
down to a minute and 43 that's over five
times faster than previous if you're
working with blender you got to download
this alpha build if you're doing renders
it is a huge difference and now we have
to do the classic we have the bmw scene
right here let's render it and we have
just under 42 seconds that is also about
five times faster than b4 so definitely
huge improvements like i said people
said it's gonna take a year or more to
get optimized look at that it's been a
month and a half since these machines
came out
and we're seeing these massive
improvements now of course this is about
five times faster some people online
said in some of their projects about
seven times faster but how does that
compare to a windows laptop so here we
go we got the razer blade advanced with
the rtx 3080 graphics card here it's got
32 gigs of ram plus 16 gigs dedicated to
that graphics card we're gonna plug it
in to 230 watts of wall power make sure
that it is in full performance so we get
the maximum results and then let's go
ahead and test that out and then after
we'll also run a test on battery and now
let's hit render i also want to monitor
the performance here so let's see what
happens when this thing starts up
alright the fans are kicking up right
now both our cpu and the graphics are
pinned and that took just over 30
seconds compared to 42 seconds with our
macbook pro so that is a significant
difference this is an easy project here
so let's go and step it up we're running
our render and this thing is flying
through it our cpu is maxed out our
graphics basically jumping between 95
and then sticking at 100 down to 95 back
to 100 let me know down below how long
you think this will take and how much
faster it's going to be than the m1 max
macbook pro all right guys we have a
result
and i'm quite surprised our m1 max
macbook pro take a minute and 43 seconds
this thing just finished it in a minute
and 39.46
base is still a minute and 39 if we
round down to a little bit faster so is
that like what four seconds faster than
the m1 max with the alpha build um this
is a lot tougher project than the bmw
one that is surprisingly really close
and now it is time to unplug this beast
of a laptop and see how it performs as a
laptop of course the macbook pro
performs the same plugged in or
unplugged we've shown you guys that and
with this you are going from 105 watts
down to about 46
which is pretty much the peak that the
m1 max graphics the 32 cores will use
let's go ahead and we're going to test
out our bmw scene first the rtx 3080
peaked at about 94 performance but it's
sitting roughly 75
on average and the cpu is just about 32
so it's definitely being limited when
we're unplugging from that 230 watts and
our test is now finished and that took a
minute and two seconds using both the
cpu and the gpu render on battery power
so that is about 48 slower than our m1
max macbook pro so when we're plugged in
for this scene the rtx 3080 is about 40
faster but when we unplug it 48 slower
now of course if you're doing serious
work if you're at your office wherever
you're going to plug in but for those
times where you don't have access or you
want to be portable you guys see the
performance so they're kind of trading
blows but now let's go ahead and jump
into the tougher project and here in the
classroom scene we are getting more
graphics usage with spikes up to a
hundred percent gpu which is good to see
it took three minutes and 33 seconds and
the macbook on battery takes one minute
and 43. so that is basically just over
twice as slow as the macbook and when
they're plugged in a very similar
performance slightly faster with the rtx
3080 in this very difficult classroom
scene so there you guys go you guys see
the performance between these systems of
course there's more optimation
optimizations that are going to be made
for our macbook but so far you guys see
there's a huge improvement we saw just
over five times improvement compared to
previously not that we use cpu and gpu
for cycles uh and although it is not as
good as performance as an rtx 3080
laptop
it's much much closer and then if you're
somebody that doesn't want to render on
battery power which i know most of you
guys don't you're gonna be plugged in
you see there is a nice boost with the
same wattage 46 watts with the 3080 and
i believe it's like 43 watts um regular
usage with m1 max peaking at 46 as well
so about the same amount of power being
fed so you guys let me know what do you
think about this the probably the
biggest weakest link with m1 max was 3d
rendering performance and now we see in
just a month and a half or so the
improvements that have been made and
there's going to be a lot more
improvements coming up so thank you guys
for watching once again make sure to
subscribe if you guys want to see our
top downsides of the m1 max and these
new 14 and 16 inch macbooks you click
one of those videos over there if you
guys want to check out some detailed
comparisons this max and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you